all right let's get into audience
questions first question david
why have opposite why has opposition to
covet guidelines
been primarily a right-wing thing
in the united states the in the united
states piece is interesting
i don't know if opposition in other
countries has been from the political
right or not
there has been some covet guideline
opposition
from the left there are some i think
there's a subreddit called like
liberal lockdown skeptics or something
along those lines but you're absolutely
right that it's been mostly from the
political right and i think there's a
couple different things going on
first of all there's this sort of
cartoonish idea
of liberty and freedom that exists on
the right
more so than it does on the left and
it's not that the left doesn't believe
in liberty and freedom but the left has
a less cartoonish concept of what that
means so
for example on the right things like
liberty and freedom
are often assigned to i can disregard
anyone else's public health concerns and
do whatever the hell i want that's
freedom and liberty on the right on the
left
we tend to see freedom and liberty more
as
we have the freedom and liberty to live
our lives
working wherever we find it to be most
rewarding
without having to consider whether we
will have health
insurance at this job versus that job
that's the kind of freedom and liberty
we talk about on the left so obviously
that right-wing concept of freedom and
liberty is going to lead people down the
path of
needing to wear masks businesses uh
restaurants having to be takeout only no
no no that's violating my
my freedom and liberty the other thing
was
certainly trump related and what i mean
by that is
um trump did nothing early and
trump didn't wear masks and trump was
skeptical of what was being done
in different uh in different parts of
the
uh country with regard to certain
governors and so on and so forth so
by definition what trump wanted was
seeing as
seen as the thing for freedom and what
anybody else wanted was seen
seen as a restriction on so-called
freedoms if you were suggesting
something other than what trump was
suggesting or doing
importantly then you were the enemy and
it was bad and you were restricting
people's freedoms
since coronavirus began during the trump
presidency
in an election year there was this
understanding
that anybody suggesting uh something
be done differently than what trump
wanted was essentially an indictment of
trump's response
which of course required much indictment
it was one of the worst five responses
in the world according to
a recent study and what continues to get
me about that even now with donald trump
gone
is that as much as the virus handling
was trump's undoing
it could have guaranteed his re-election
it was a wasted
opportunity trump and the republican
party all they
had to do was stand aside and say what
do the experts say
oh they say masks we're printing
american flag
masks we want to get them out to
everybody instead of
rejecting the idea of having the postal
service distribute masks to everybody
they could have said yes
the postal service will be bringing
everybody five american flag masks it's
the patriotic thing to do
they could have passed uh uh you know
they could pass
what they passed and more to serve as a
bridge
to dealing with the virus and trump
would have sailed to re-election and
republicans likely would still control
the senate so
the the idea that it had to go the way
it went down political lines with the
anti-massacres and the anti-closures and
guidelines people
saying they are violating our freedom
they are treading on us and so on
because of the
tone that was set by trump that was all
optional
however for trump to have handled it
differently would have required trump to
be a different person
the exact same narcissistic tendencies
that are what a lot of people uh were
drawn to trump by
were what prevented donald trump from
doing what i suggested from the
beginning which is saying
let's do what the doctors say let's be
patriots
it'll be tough but we're all going to do
it together
um if trump had had sort of bought into
that he wouldn't have been trump in a
sense and that's part of why he was
unable to do it i do
think trump's base would have followed
him i got a few emails saying you know
if trump had done the stuff you're
suggesting his base wouldn't have
followed him
um i think that trump's base was more
than willing to be led
in absolutely any direction at any point
in time
and um it was uh listen trump would have
had a second term had he dealt with it
properly